high-pitch Ark is on the phone my pitch
I high pitch is like hanging down
high-pitched what are you gonna do like
hang out at the lobby and stuff Jewish
rapper yeah I don't care what can we
have him do
oh here's Benjy Benjy will you kiss him
tom kiss nice we kissed on the lips if
you would wash them off first all right
all right come up here take your shirt
off a kiss Benjy on the Left what do you
want with that you just want to be on
the show in the Jewish rapper has to
come up I tell you what yeah you come up
here you take your shirt off okay and
you kiss Benjy on the lips yeah I'll let
the Jewish rapper guys say it just for
like 30 seconds say some stuff oh god
your body is hideous hyper jerk is
hideous rub the boo-boo get Benjy out
here all right there's hyper jerk
shirtless hold on we'll get the Jewish
robber in here for a minute why are you
doing this for the Jewish rapper yeah
what do you get out of it
Hank you're even disgusted by high-pitch
Eric right Wow as long as he doesn't do
anything right all right Benji Benji you
gonna kiss hyperedge Eric he's not
kissing me all right
all right go ahead you guys kissing no
not like that it's disgusting
what is that what is that what's the
name of that fantastic he just poured on
your lips though it does not say
anything about don't swallow it
oh my job why is this on this black tape
over here that's the label fantastic on
your lips just kiss the guy real quick
and also this doesn't mean anything all
right just a moment this is just an
America you high perch are you gay voice
bye all these girls I talked to right
look at the bars you could turn down
from this make sure they you're thinking
like maybe your are you attracted to
Benji no thank you's a nice guy veggie
finally meet with some success veggies
veggies a wife who's been she was
explaining to me I'm enthralled from
Hank coughing up Benji was just
explaining to me that Eric's gonna kiss
him but he's not gonna give him back
I say it's gonna be a half-hearted gift
yes I I said I will passively accept a
kiss there's no tongue if they stop if
they stick a circle up between us
there's no tongue going on kiss kiss a
hyper jerk
Fido
oh my that's what most disgusting things
I've ever saw flips yeah what did that
feel like
like a slug on my lips kind of like to
[ __ ] so you would like to do it again
all right listen what is okay now the
hyper jerk you've earned the right to
introduce us to the Jewish robber yes
Eric have you ever had sex with a man
seriously
no you've not now have you ever kissed a
man with your mouth open I don't know
you're very attractive
oh you know what I thought my legs are
shaking so nervous it's you like it's
risen all right what is with this Jewish
rapper what do you do you wrap it we do
rap tunes yeah I do a rap time with a
band called slack rock and I'm the
rapper I'm the energy on the unbridled
you want to do a little something for us
you have to roll your friend here just
help you out these guys are actually
famous in the Jewish world I've heard of
them really Jewish world the Jewish
world is right out on the street here
it's called Manhattan go ahead and and
let me hear you rap now I did give you
something um it's Friday night and I'm
back from sure I smell the food and I
start to drool shalom aleichem has
already been said I bless the children
but before we start kicking the kiddush
on the grape wine and i know pretty soon
everything will be fine so we washed
this way and wash that way we make the
blessing now it's time to say the Moche
Megan Megan - Megan - Megan MOT ayo ayo
Megan emotes e Megan Megan Megan Megan
emotes e AO after I eat my piece of
bread I think it realized what I have
said praise and thanks to the one above
the creator of the world who I know and
love now I have a big smile
I do not fry because I know that it's
time to munch on down on everything
that's sitting right on my plate all
because I just made I made a mochi
making a mega mega motif all right very
good you get it I could see white white
Jewish
all right well thank you to all our
whole panel I got to share every range
of emotion went through me during this
exciting interview I've never seen
anything like it